[Music]
kevin is in denver hi kevin how are you
doing pretty good how are you better
than i deserve what's up in your world
well i could use some help with getting
my debt snowball going and i'm having
trouble with the zero-sum budget
um i believe i'm on baby step number two
okay you got a thousand dollars
uh five
you have five thousand dollars
yes okay good well baby step one is one
thousand dollars baby step two is we
list all of our debts smallest to
largest
pay minimum payments on everything but
the little one and attack the little one
with any money we can find from any
source and that would include four
thousand dollars which is the five the
four above the one and so we're going to
throw that at the smallest debt that's
definitely going to get you rolling
what's your very smallest debt
my smallest debt is i believe two
hundred and thirty dollars all right
it's gone what's the next one
what's that what's the next one
the next one is i'll have it right here
um
five thousand three hundred
fifteen go from two hundred fifty
dollars to five thousand dollars
well see um i have a life insurance loan
i have a retirement loan
and um the only other
all my
utilities are basically paid i got them
on automatic pay yeah
utilities are not a debt that's a budget
item
okay yeah so you you and life insurance
loans going to be gone are you healthy
can you get life insurance
uh actually i have some some issues you
know i have um
obesity
um high blood pressure well actually
it's not high anymore but i have a
history of it yeah if you can get some
term insurance it'll probably be cheaper
than the whole life and then the whole
life being cancelled will pay off that
loan that is not a loan you want to
repay that's a loan you want to get rid
of by getting rid of that policy
uh how much do you owe on your
retirement account
uh 3
500.
3056. okay so your second smallest debt
is the retirement account
yeah okay
so if you had four thousand dollars in
your hand you could pay off those first
two debts correct do you have any other
debt
i do i have student loans both me and my
wife have i have 63 000 and student
loans and my wife has 119.
what do you guys make of here
a little over 100. okay all right now
then but so we knock off these two
little first debts and we're gonna with
some of the money you had in savings
taking you down to one thousand we're
gonna get you on that zero-based budget
and get you going and uh meaning that
every dollar just has an assignment
before the month begins each and every
month every dollar has an assignment
that's all it means
the every dollar app will help you do
that and i'm going to sign you up for a
year
for ramsey plus and that's going to
allow you to you and your wife to go
through financial peace university
there's a really good bunch of lessons
in there on how to do that zero-based
budget and the every dollar premium app
is part of it i'm going to pay for all
of it
and give it to you free the only thing i
ask that you do is you get your butt out
of debt
get yourself straightened up and then
you go help somebody else someday but
with your generosity because you're not
broke anymore that's what i want you to
do so you hold on and kelly will get you
signed up and we'll get you moving in
the right direction and here's the deal
kevin when you and your wife sit down
every week and say what's our budget
look like
go ahead and say what is our calendar
going to look like
what are three or four things we can do
to move our bodies this week we go for a
walk together after dinner
can we go for a walk in the morning
together when we're just going to look
out and not even say anything to one
another to have our cough whatever it
but what you're going to see is a level
of intentionality that starts with your
money that ends up with your marriage
and your relationship and your calendar
and what work looks like and what
physical fitness is going to look like
and you're going to find you said you
struggle with obesity and high blood
pressure you're going to find that that
level intentionality is going to begin
to to slowly invade all corners of your
life
and you're gonna wake up in a year two
years three years you're gonna be out of
debt you're gonna be making a little bit
more money your marriage is gonna be
different your health is gonna be
different and all of this stuff begins
to work together with that one magic
word intentionality right there's a
saying that discipline begets discipline
every time but what really happens is
that
once you take
the initiative
in one area of your life whatever that
area is and you say
i can control
my behavior in this area
and then you have some success with that
it just says well i could control this
other area then
and then oh maybe i could control this
other area the number of times
that
we see someone
get out of debt
simultaneously improve their marriage
simultaneously lose weight
and it's not because they weren't eating
because they were living on beans and
rice that's not the point they were it's
just the discipline they just we had a
guy in here one time did a debt-free
scream lost 260 pounds while he was
getting out of debt i mean he was just
it was an amazing story we actually did
a youtube special on him and put it on
our youtube channel it was a beautiful
story but there's that that thing of
once i know that i can make me do
something i can do hard stuff that's
right then i know i can make me do
something else and something else and
something else there's a confidence that
builds
uh in your ability to control your
environment and there's this confidence
that's built with dave we are so
we are so beholden to these
magical things called feelings i don't
feel like working out this morning i
don't feel like eating i feel like
eating that instead of that i feel like
buying this thing and there's something
about learning
here's a budget and i want to buy this
but i'm not going to because i said it
wasn't going to and then you start to
realize oh i need to feel these feelings
but they don't always tell me the truth
they don't have to live by them anymore
and i didn't feel like running this
morning dave you probably didn't feel
like get up and go for but we did it and
we're gonna do it again tomorrow and you
can do it again tomorrow the feelings
sometimes don't matter it's that
discipline i can do it i can do hard
stuff i can do harder to live only by
feelings that's the definition of being
a child there you go
i mean adults are allowed to have
feelings but not live by that you've got
to challenge it that's right you know
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good that's right
because when you're when you're
basically a child whether you're living
in an adult body or not all you do is
what feels good but it feels good i
don't feel like it i don't feel like i'm
in love anymore i don't feel like i want
to be a dad anymore i don't feel like i
want to be a mom anymore i don't feel
like i want to work anymore i don't feel
like i and everything's about you
you selfish little brat you know and
we've all got that kid that lives inside
of us but this thing called growing up
is when you say in spite of the feelings
i'm also going to do what is wise
and what is good and what is noble and
do it anyway do it again
i'm gonna go for a walk this morning i
know it's raining but i haven't missed a
day in 517 days and i'm going for a walk
this morning i know that me and my wife
are um
not talking great i'm still gonna get up
and make her coffee right and i'm still
going to say good morning how are you
i'm still going to do those things even
when i don't feel like it and you're
going to see that just bear fruit over
years and years later man that's what's
so weird about this whole get out of
that thing it's like that snowball okay
we just paid off the first two nets
right just now just now did it while he
was on the air on the air and uh i mean
he hadn't done it yet but i tell him
what to do and so you know the the that
gives you this sense of oh look at that
i can control it i can just do this i
can i can make some progress and we make
a hundred thousand dollars a year let's
uh try let's save it up for the next
month the next month and pay off the
next one right let's get on it let's get
this next year you actually took off
three of them because he's going to go
and cancel that whole term policy he's
going to get a whole life policy um a
term life policy and um he's gonna go
from there right that's a good good
point yeah so he got three debts taking
off in one phone call right so it's just
that i i don't feel like it i'm gonna do
it anyway and you know what he didn't
pay anything for that free advice and
free and i gave him the whole thing from
a couple of handsome guys that's what
you get man
where are they i don't know
they're back there with kelly and ben
yeah the next segment is on delusional
yes
i just i wish
everyone can see the power of saying i
don't feel like i'm gonna do it anyway
and you do that 30 days and you do it 60
days unit 90 days and literally
everything in your life changes
everything and you begin to build new
brain synapse your brain changes your
body changes your mind changes your
money change everything changes it takes
30 days 60 days 90 days but what happens
when you build confidence like that
that's called faith hope yes
you know
and hope you you can control that's
right you can decide to look for it yeah
and and
when you don't have it it's called a
broken heart
you know the proverb says hope deferred
makes the heart sick that's right
but when desire comes
it is the tree of life i love it you can
go looking for beauty and hope you can
find it it's well and you can actually
manufacture it every single day
ah i love it man little hope factory